[MUSIC PLAYING]
So here we are on the last day
of the recording for the
Christmas Lectures, but
I thought I'd take an
opportunity to point this out
because it's so beautiful.
This is a really stunning cloud
chamber, and the tracks
that you can see here show just
the natural radiation in
the atmosphere around us.
So if we actually have a look in
here, you can see sometimes
there are thicker tracks which
are big heavy alpha particles.
Sometimes they're little
wispy ones,
which are beta particles.
But all of these, they're all
working in the same way.
So the atmosphere in
here contains a
lot vapour of alcohol.
And it's sort of more
than it should have.
And when these charged particles
fire through the
atmosphere in here, they cause
little droplets to form, and
those are the clouds
that you're seeing.
So this is a similar sort of
thing to when you get a track
behind an airplane.
There's a lot of moisture in the
atmosphere and it's just
the exhaust, just helping those
drops of moisture to
form together and leave
that cloud.
And this is a tiny little
sample of the
element called Americium.
And this is used in
smoke detectors.
So you've probably got some of
this in your home, at least
you should have.
So this is an artificially
produced metal.
And as soon as this is
introduced, look at that.
What we're seeing here are
tracks from the alpha
particles emitted from this
radioactive source.
And these alpha particles, with
their two protons, two
neutrons, and they
grab electrons
and form Helium atoms.
So what you're seeing here are
the birth of Helium atoms.
[MUSIC PLAYING]